the kids at school said the steelers  aren't for real the steelers are real  if you believe i don't think this movie  ends well did you beat the chiefs but  almost lose to the jets  that seems pretty specific man  introducing the seventh seed now even  bad teams can make the playoffs can we  get a coach please  i won and i want it i want it  [Music]  i'm here to get one of these fancy seven  seats only one fluffing available dad  goodman my kids get it  oh fighter 2 reminder the 7th seed is  also available in  nfc vikings oh yeah maybe phil over here  tough freaking play jacoby it's  beginning to look  a lot like big dress up this is what my  kid deserves  thanks that's not you  all right now i got to get a present for  my 61 other kids  [Music]  help help there's a strange steel worker  in my house no no  i'm stealing i'm your mascot get him tj  what  oh oh it hurts christmas is ruined